[Music]  let it burn  i can't see you shake my hand  [Music]  [Music]  um  my grandmother was right the boogeyman  was real  it's over we can't hurt anyone ever  again  no one told you told me what  somebody in there  [Music]  michael myers  stop you had a knife in your stomach you  and allison  should not have to keep running evil  dies tonight  [Music]  i'm not just gonna sit and watch another  innocent person die  if you track michael's victims that's a  straight line  to michael's childhood home  what do we do we fight let's hunt him  down  michael myers is flesh and blood  but a man couldn't have survived that  fire  the more he kills the more he transcends  run go home now he's the essence of evil  do it  you want your math come and get it  i'm coming for you michael  you